[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
bin gerade im john deere forum und darf
auf dem traktor sitzen während der
traktor wird nämlich 100 jahre alt und
seit diesem anlass habe ich mir gedacht
komm zwar keine 3d torte viele von euch
haben sich ja bereits einen traktor
gewünscht heute ist der tag und dann
werde ich die torte am geburtstag
übergeben
ich backe arbeitet orten nicht alleine
zu hause ich habe unterstützung nicht
von john d aber mindestens genauso
wichtig kommt mit in die küche zu gast
habe ich bei mir mag von penns vorstand
bei john deere im bereich der
landmaschinen was macht man denn als
vorstand wo den ganzen tag ist eine gute
frage
also man kümmert sich um sicherlich um
seine mitarbeiter seien bemüht sich um
seine kunden aber so ein unternehmen
gehörte aktionären die kann man auch
nicht ganz vernachlässigen das sind so
die drei dinge eingesetzt werden kann
und lieber wie viele mitarbeiter
sprechen
in deutschland sind wir 12.000
mitarbeiter weltweit über 60.000
mitarbeiter also das ist schon eine ganz
ordentliche portionen sind hier bei uns
in wahlkreisen haben wir 23.000
einwohner also schon sehr beeindruckend
das aber ist mitgebracht genau das ist
jetzt nicht da ist ein gps-empfänger
alles klar
ich habe jetzt heute mal was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich meinen lieblings
kuchen gebacken das ist der mississippi
der leckerste schokokuchen auf der welt
würde ich jetzt mal behaupten das rezept
gibt es natürlich auch schon online und
den dürfen wir auch gleich probieren
du brauchst mich suzuki klingt schon
nach blondieren ja schon so ein bisschen
also der kuchen heißt ja so weil er beim
backen risse bekommt und dann sieht er
aus wie die ufer des mississippi
das hat schon der mit mississippi zu tun
john deere kommt von den ufern des
mississippi
1837 von einem hufschmied gegründet der
den selbstreinigenden stahl flug dort
erfunden hat und das unternehmen von
dort aus in die welt geführt hat und
inzwischen über 180 jahre alt ist
wahnsinn und jetzt wird der traktor
schon 100 jahre alles genau
wir haben vor etwa 100 jahren in
nordamerika und waterloo in einer
traktorenfabrik
gekauft und damit kam der traktor ins
geschäft ist hochumstritten damals so
sollte man das überhaupt machen und
nachhinein fragt man sich was wären wir
ohne traktoren aber so ist das in der
geschichte stehen hinter pastor auch
richtig gut drauf ich finde wir sollten
vielleicht sogar den mississippi matt
packen und dann mit große fläche machen
dann können wir das nämlich auch bei der
übergabe bei der veranstaltung gehen nur
bei der geburtstagsfeier den gästen
anbieten das heißt wir backen gleich
zusammen denn nichts ist bei vorher mal
probieren ob perfekt auf dem sims
brettern oder mähdrescher und traktoren
solutions genau jetzt schon so eine
liebes marke geld machen eher eine art
marker bekannt wie mercedes benz hier
und die kinder werden damit groß und
haben tolle auf jeden fall aber was
macht er denn john deere traktor vor auf
der erste zuverlässig und erster
innovativ das sind so die hauptmerkmale
der verbraucht wenig kraftstoff ok und
ist verdammt bequem
ja das stimmt ich sage schon mal in
einem im job de/forum ich mal gespannt
hmm das machen wir heute machen
bist du dir sicher dass wirtschaft
wahrscheinlich glaubt schauen das ist
nicht ganz so schwer
der traktor jahr da ich mir auch schon
ein paar zeichnungen gemacht
mag sein ja in 3d also haben viel und
habe einfach den traktor ausgemessen mir
aufgeschrieben hatten im späteren leben
werde ich wahrscheinlich mal ingenieur
und was geschieht damit und das kann
waren aus dem prinzip kann man das
eigentlich auch verlosen wir am ende des
videos ein ganz tolles gewinnspiel gibt
es ganz toller gewinn preise von john
deere und dieses buch da habe ich meine
aufschrieb drin
und vielleicht können wir noch alles
reinschreiben was persönliches und das
mit hallo
klar also anders gezeichneten größe der
scheune greifen alles mag ja jetzt auch
meine freundin da und mit ihrer
zweijährigen tochter und sie sagt
doch gleich papa kabine macht papa
kabine macht also der papa macht
dicaprio schon jetzt noch gut
echt toll dass ich etwas mitgebracht
geht aus ersten blick des gelben
bauhelmen aber es ist nicht ja das ist
unser spiegelei also dahinter verbirgt
sich ein gps-empfänger starfire heißt
das da werden die maschinen bis noch 1
zentimeter genau im feld gesteuert ok
und sagte auch was über den
gesundheitszustand des bodens auf das
kommt eben auch der hat also auch eine
verbindung zu dem gerät und haben die
daten die auf den geräten aufgenommen
werden werden zum traktor geschickt und
von dort zu erfahren oder zum händler
oder landwirtschaftlichen berater das
passiert also auch gerade das nennt sich
digitale landwirtschaft wahnsinn also
ein richtig intelligenter traktor der
traktor ist hochintelligent hat also
hohe rechenleistungen aber die ganze
arbeit drumherum muss ja auch vernetzt
werden und bei den landwirten geht es ja
immer darum nachhaltig auch zu
wirtschaften das heißt also dass gleich
oder mehr in der höheren qualität zu
erwirtschaften mit weniger aufwand
weniger düngemittel weniger spritzmittel
in nachhaltiger form denn so landwirte
haben schon viel im kopf die müssen ja
viel wissen im unternehmen
sie müssen agronomische gut auf sein
wenn sie viel haltung haben müssen sie
das alles beherrschen also halbe bittere
lehre sein und dann können sie doch
alles richtig machen und dann ist das
wetter entweder zu trocken oder feucht
und dann haben sie trotzdem keine ernte
also als landwirt muss man schon nerven
haben dabei sagt man immer die dummen
bauern überhaupt nicht mehr sagt kennt
sich ein wenig mit landwirtschaft aus
wenn man sieht was man hier alles machen
kann und muss heutzutage dann muss man
eigentlich den hut vor den landwirten
wahnsinn
also das darf er macht sozusagen den
traktor intelligent genau wie kann ich
denn neben und auf das auto vom anpacken
dass er den schulort und wollen würden
noch in münster haben das fest unter dem
das mit der lenkung dann fährt er ein
zentimeter genau die schule hasst
nämlich schon geschafft die kinder
einzupacken ins auto wenn man seinen
gedanken dann ist ein globus markt
gelandet ware einkaufen dürfen
und bei uns geht es seit zehn jahren
schon machen wir das mit dieser
automatischen lenkung das themenfeld
automatisch seine spur fahren kann
und wir kennen die feld grenzen und der
fahrer sitzt nur noch zur überwachung
dort richtig schön das heißt der bauer
hat dann sozusagen viel mehr kraft und
viel mehr zeit um sich um andere
wichtige dinge zu können
mannheim bauen wir eben die traktoren
das ist das kernbank der 1956 habt schon
die allianz gekauft oder auch eine
traditionsmarke und seitdem sie die
traktoren aber nur in geld geworden und
marktführer seit über 18 jahren in
deutschland braucht er ganz ganz stolz
sind und uns das natürlich auch jeden
tag wieder verdienen müssen bei den
kunden erkennen und deswegen findet auch
die geburtstagsfeier in mannheim statt
die bi software findet in mannheim statt
der bulldog ist noch nicht ganz 100
jahre alt aber der erste john deere
traktor ist 1918 entstanden durch einen
zukauf dieser firma eben und deswegen
feiern wir das auch gebührend nein also
ich muss sowieso also musst du geh'n wir
nicht an traktoren denkt dann habe ich
immer grün gelb kopf sogar den augen das
ist vor 100 jahren eben hat das begonnen
mit dem ziel raus kam die farbe grün
gelb damit rein
außerdem sind die maschinen grün und die
folgen in der regel gilt also für mich
sei jetzt auch eine herausforderung den
traktor in 3d zu backen
deswegen bin auch schon ein bisschen
aufgeregt die zeichnung stehen zwar
schon aber praktisch habe ich noch
nichts gemacht
ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt mal an
mit dem mississippi matthey kann man ein
bisschen einarbeiten grund schon mal die
basis klar auf blitze aufgeht steht an
und los geht's kuchen besteht aus zwei
bestandteilen einmal möglich den habe
ich schon vorbereitet er kommt ins
fläche mit vorgebacken und du darfst
dich füllung machen
aber jetzt bin ich hier wie bei käpt'n
blaubär der nicht allzu schlaue küchen
assistent oder nein alles gut machen
voll vor wer aus der opel
da ist zuerst die butter in den topf
geben und dann die schokolade und damit
meldeten wir die zutaten wie ganz okay
ja es ist ein bisschen kalorienreicher
kuchen verteilt sich kein weight
watchers rezept und hat auch noch nie
gebacken
doch früher aber in letzter zeit selten
wie man das so macht zu weihnachten zu
hause bei den eltern oder sonst wo
meistens zu der zeit oder aber eher
weniger okay jetzt kann sich hier gern
schon die eier mit dem zucker und kakao
farbe okay also ein verbrannten alles
mitgehen
auch den ganzen zucker
[Musik]
auch leiter so genau auch das so dass
man nur kräftig hören dass es sich auf
der bindung genau das verbindet sich
dann irgendwann gehe es liegt am
fettgehalt verkauft und dann verbindet
sich das irgendwann mit den eiern
also bei uns in der küche was mein mann
hat einmal für mich gekocht und dann ist
da die kühe hier danach so schlimm aus
dass ich gesagt habe okay lass es lieber
ich mach das selber und war dann die
taktik also erkannt sondern sie kommt
bestimmt von anfang an aber ich habe da
habe ich danach mehr arbeit
lasst es bleiben bei uns war das so
ähnlich erdähnliche naja deswegen bin
ich auf die küchen assistenten rolle
verfallen da darf jetzt auch gerne die
schokolade schon mit rein nämlich genau
die zwei bestandteile die schmerzen
müssen alles auch gezielt ja mal
probieren ja das extrakt oder verletzt
ich will ich auch nicht unter druck
setzen aber du weißt nie war jetzt alles
schlecht machen dann haben wir die
ganzen gäste am mittwoch nichts ok also
nur also ich gebe mir alle da war ja
also bitte immer sagen was guckt ja es
geht schon los
die gäste die werden sich freuen einigen
wir die erfahren was der hintergrund der
sache ist und passiert ist du kommst ja
auch und stellst das war super ich habe
nur ein bisschen angst vor der autofahrt
mithalten aber das kriegen wir schon
irgendwie hin dass man gutes konstrukt
bauen und basteln an dass ein traktor
nicht gerne kaputt geht
[Musik]
ich habe gehört die kalorien verbrennen
im ofen bei 190 grad
ach so ja umso besser dass ich dir jetzt
sagen oder später das war das ganze
jetzt noch acht mal machen müssen
ja das hat keiner vorher gesagt denn das
band wird so groß sehen ob ich hab mir
kriegen das schon hin
2 gesetzt gut vor geboten
das macht mal auch damit der schön
knusprig wird in der hochphase ich weiß
schon die risse und sahen wir schon die
russen jetzt kommt die leckere füllung
rein einfach drüber oder gibt es einen
trick ich am besten vom körper weg sonst
also werde jetzt auch hier noch ein
bisschen was für uns machen noch die
ganzen fläche fertig und dann geht es
schon mit dem traktor los also ich freue
mich schon richtig auf mittwoch auf die
geburtstagsfeier ich hoffe die torte
kommt dort gut an und kommt bei den
gästen oder stimmt hunderte die schon
die noch gar nicht wissen was da
passiert aber die bestimmt total
überrascht
ich glaube viele werden begeistert sein
dass du mir geholfen hast hier den
mississippi mattheis und marco spaß
gemacht ja geld habe ich weiß schon was
ich nächstes wochenende zu hause machen
muss
vielen dank für deinen das sogar hat mir
freude gemacht
ja danke ich sehen uns damit was okay
bisher dankeschön
tschüss und bei uns geht es hier weiter
mit der torte ich zeige euch nochmal
eine skizze meine planung und dann
starten wir direkt ich bin ein bisschen
aufgeregt ist noch immer die torte nur
einmal und ich hoffe das gelingt
[Musik]
der staat ist mit dem detail ist die
trocknen und fest werden müssen
das in meinem fall die reifen und damit
ich die nicht aus kuchenteig machen muss
verwende ich dafür die reis crispy masse
also eine masse aus schoko christie's
und marshmallows die wird nämlich schön
fest und es aber auch schön leicht und
der kuchen also der traktor zerstört
später auch die reifen nicht und drückt
sie nicht durch
dafür nehme ich jetzt die marshmallows
und schmelze in der mikrowelle und
verbinde sie dann ganz kurz mit den reis
christie's und der mutter
[Musik]
die masse muss jetzt noch in form
gepresst werden da wird die streifen
raus bekommen und ich werde meine hände
immer gerne mit back trends gray und
natürlich auch die unterlage auf dich
arbeite ich benutze jetzt einen
tortenring da hat 20 cm im durchmesser
und der reifen wird ja auch 20 cm im
durchmesser und 7,5 cm hoch das heißt
das jetzt schon fetten und dann kann
nicht die masse reindrücken
[Musik]
auf diese weise stelle jetzt auch die
restlichen reifen her
lassen sie dann über nacht komplett
aushärten und dann werden sie erst
dekoriert als nächstes ist die kapelle
dran dies im original natürlich aus glas
ich werde das glas mit isomalt machen
also mit einem zuckeraustauschstoff den
man wirklich toll schmelzen und dann
gießen kann für die struktur hier außen
rum also für den rahmen verwende ich
jetzt blüten passte weil die wunderbar
aushärtet und dann einen schönen rahmen
bildet die blüten passt habe ich bereits
weiß gekneteten rolle sie jetzt auf 5 mm
stärke aus und bevor ich das ganze jetzt
so schneide bastele ich mir aus papier
23 schablonen damit ich einfach eine
richtlinie habe die front um die
rückseite das sind einfach das ist
einfach nur rechtecke bei den
seitenteilen wird ein bisschen
komplizierter ich habe nämlich die
rundungen dabei vom rad und hier ist nur
wichtig denn durchmesser vom reifen zu
beachten dort hinten 21 cm die abdeckung
muss ein bisschen größer sein also etwa
22 und die habe ich ja noch mal ein
bisschen abstand also mache ich hier zur
sicherheit 23 cm
dafür könnt ihr den zettel nehmen oder
einfach nur back ring den auf 23
einstellen und dann habe ich einfach
hier den abstand gemessen und hier habe
mir das hier markiert natürlich in
meinem maßen und jetzt kann ich den ring
hier drauflegen und zwar so dass hat
diese beiden punkte trifft und da kommt
die rundungen
[Musik]
und jetzt schneide ich mir hier die
streifen zurecht und legte dann auf eine
back folie einfach damit sie da schön
aus herten können
[Musik]
und zum zusammenkleben verwende ich s
bahn kleber
[Musik]
nach dem vollständigen trocknen wird die
blüten passte dann mit flüssiger schwarz
metallic farbe bemalt zuerst die
vorderseite und nach dem trocknen
natürlich auch die rückseite die kabine
schließt oben mit diesen grünen deckel
ab und dafür mische ich jetzt etwas von
deutscher wird hier grün und gibt noch
ein bisschen geld mit rein und damit das
ganze auch aushärten kann ein bisschen
zellulose pulver also 10 10
ihr könnt natürlich auch buyten passte
verwenden müsste dann die blüten passte
aber grün einfärben und damit ich später
weiß wie das verhältnis von grün zu gelb
war um den richtigen john deere ton zu
treffen
wirklich die gelbe farbe ab und kann mir
später dann immer wieder den gleichen
farbton mission
[Musik]
denn von dort habe ich jetzt gleichmäßig
dünn ausgerollt und jetzt kann ich
einfach die vorlage nehmen das heißt den
traktor
die formel nach meinen maßen zu
schneiden
[Musik]
die um marshmallow masse ist jetzt fest
und ich hab's ja auch den tortenring
herausgelöst und habe hier für die
felgen schon ein loch vorgebohrt ich
zeige euch gleich wie das geht
hier vorne steht alex da alex ist unser
freund und feind und er macht gerade die
holzkonstruktion denn die torte muss ja
erhöht sein
das ist übrigens die platte wo der
mississippi drauf kommt wo ungefähr 1000
leute davon essen können
ich habe mir viel vorgenommen vielleicht
auch mal 100 ich weiß nicht je nachdem
wie viel sie essen und hier habe ich
einfach vor dem grundriss vom traktor
gezeichnet und haben wir das oder hatte
alex ist so besagt es kommt hier erhöht
und dann kommt da die reifen dran usw
und während der alex mich nach vorne
unterstützt kann ich jetzt hier mit den
reifen weiter machen und zwar braucht
ihr jetzt entweder einen ausstecher oder
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel einen teller
verwenden
ich habe jetzt hier einmal dieses große
paket und dann nimmt jetzt ein scharfes
messer und halbiert das ganz wichtig
und dann einfach eine hälfte ausstechen
und am besten leicht gesalzen brett
drauf dann habt ihr nämlich viel mehr
kraft und könnte es runter drücken
jetzt setzt sich die grabflächen nach
außen das heißt hier so zusammen und die
reifen werden jetzt auch mit etwas
gestrichen und dann mit schwarzem von
dort oder mit schwarzer modelliert
schokolade überzogen
[Musik]
ich habe zum einen saftigen schokokuchen
bereits vor gebacken
ich habe ich meine platte und jetzt kam
zurecht geschnitten umgeschichtet werden
den kuchen habe ich jetzt auf zwei
flächen gebacken damit er schön flach
ist und ich ihnen nicht durchschneiden
muss jetzt verwende ich meine holzplatte
schneidet den kuchen zurecht und fülle
ihn dann mit der garage ich messe
zwischendurch auch immer wieder die höhe
des modells traktors damit auch das
verhältnis stimmt
man erkennt es noch nicht aber es wird
ein traktor
ich nehme einfach immer wieder die
vorlage messe die abstände ab und so
kommt es erst mal im kühlschrank da fest
werden und dann wird der gesamte komplex
hier mit ghanas bestrichen mit der
garage kann ich die torte dann
bestreichen damit der untergrund wird
und von dort schön glatt ist die erste
schicht bildet die kuchen krümmel und
die zweite schicht macht die torte glatt
jetzt sind die profile dran
dafür habe ich die modelle mazda schon
auf 5 mm stärke ausgerollt die
modelliermasse schneide ich dann in
dünne streifen und biege vielleicht zu
recht damit sie auf den reifen passen
und auch aussehen wie beim original und
anschließend las ich sie dann trocknen
die reifen müssen gar nicht so perfekt
aussehen jetzt werden sie mit back
trends besprüht und hier kommt jetzt
schwarzer von dort drauf den habe ich
auch mit cnc verknetet jetzt einfach
vorsichtig darüber legen dann auf den
kopf stellen und die reste hier oben
verbinden und dann wegschneiden
ganz schnell ich hier in der mitte ein
kann alles schön mit den händen glatt
form
und jetzt wird am rand auch das profil
daran geklebt
[Musik]
hier stelle ich aus schwarzer
modelliermasse die abdeckung für die
reifen herren und die muss etwa einen
zentimeter größer sein im durchmesser
als der reifen selbst danach lasse ich
die abdeckung an einem tortenring
trocknen so habe ich eben auch schön die
rundung die felgen fertige ich dann aus
gelben von da an
hier lege ich die verschiedenen streifen
hinein und klebt sie fest in die mitte
kommt dann noch eine gelbe scheibe und
mit einem voll tool oder einem anderen
modell die werkzeug drücke ich da noch
die schrauben ein
der rahmen für die kabine ist getrocknet
jetzt werden die fensterscheiben gefüllt
das mache ich jetzt mit zucker und zwar
bis jetzt so malt das hat nämlich einen
anderen schmelzpunkt als normaler zucker
und den kann ich schmerzen ohne dass es
sofort karamellisiert geschmeidig wie
jetzt einfach in einem kleinen topf und
füllten dann hier vorsichtig rein
hier habe ich etwas backpapier tun damit
ich später auch wieder schön wegnehmen
kann um die luftbläschen aus dem saal zu
entfernen klopfe ich den topf ein paar
mal auf die arbeitsfläche und dann
einfach in die form ein gießen und
aushärten lassen
[Musik]
jetzt wird die kabine zusammen gesetzt
und ich gebe es jetzt auch wieder mit
iso mal zusammen
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel racing
verwenden aber es wird schneller fest
und somit ist die kabine schneller
stabil
[Musik]
jetzt model ihre ich hier noch die
details um die kabine herum hier habe
ich ein auspuffrohr
und dieses wird jetzt hergestellt aus
schwarzer modelliermasse und jetzt
nämlich einfach einen holzstab schneiden
für recht und um mantel ihn dann mit der
schwarzen wurde leo masse
[Musik]
natürlich dürfen die kennzeichen nicht
fehlen und die schreibe ich jetzt mit
lebensmittel stiften auf weiße blüten
passte und damit sie einen rahmen haben
klebe ich die auf schwarzer
modelliermasse einzelne metallteile
werden jetzt mit metallic spray besprüht
und die lasse ich dann trocknen der
feier star receiver also die intelligenz
des traktors darf natürlich nicht fehlen
diesem modell ihre ich dann
maßstabgetreu aus grün und gelb und lass
ihn anschließend aus herten
die torte ist es schön glatt gestrichen
die garage ist auch fest jetzt habe ich
hier den grünen vom tor bereits
ausgerollt nicht zu dünn und das kann
ich die torte damit überziehen und ich
über die jetzt glaube ich erstmal den
vorderen teil und dann den hinteren
wichtig ist hier einfach die falken
rauszubekommen immer wieder denn vom tor
weg ziehen und vorsichtig an drücken und
dann die überreste wegschneiden
[Musik]
den kühlergrill kann man gut mit einem
eckigen ausstecher oder zum beispiel mit
einem messer eindrücken die reste der
reis christi masse verwende ich dann für
den innenteil der kabine
[Musik]
für den schwarzen licht blog für wenn
dich die schwarze modelliermasse und für
die lichter weiße blüten passte die deko
am rand lässt sich ganz einfach mit
etwas backpapier oder wachs papier
ankleben
[Musik]
natürlich darf hier der typische john
deere streifen nicht wählen
einzelne teile können dann mit schwarz
überzogen werden so dass es zum original
traktor passt die kabine bekommt hier
noch eine schwarze platte und ein stab
in der mitte stützt die kabine dann
zusätzlich das innenteil der kabine
sieht man nicht weil die scheiben nicht
ganz transparent sind und daher braucht
man da auch nicht mehr details
jetzt können die kleinen lichter und
kennzeichen mit isomalt oder mit erstem
kleber angeklebt werden
[Musik]
die reifen abdeckung dekoriere ich jetzt
mit grün und mit den rückleuchten
ich habe jetzt alle elemente
fertiggestellt und einige sachen müssen
noch trocknen bis morgen früh ich werde
jetzt hier aufräumen klar schiff machen
und mich dann ausruhen
morgen früh geht es nach mannheim und
ich hoffe dass ich dort vor ort darum
die torte gut zusammen gesetzt bekommen
ich musste jetzt noch so eine kochplatte
kaufen damit ich dort vor ort noch mal
so mal schmelzen und alles schön kleben
kann ich hoffe es funktioniert drückt
mir die daumen und
eine torte machen wir jetzt auch jetzt
bastele ich noch eine abdeckung für die
torte damit einen überraschungseffekt
gibt dafür sehe ich drei schicht platten
zu und säge zwei löcher als griff hinein
damit ich die platten besser aneinander
nageln kann befestige ich sie zuerst mit
etwas heißkleber so braucht man nämlich
keine 511 anderer seite
anschließend kann ich die nägel
einschlagen und die kabine grün
streichen
[Musik]
torten und einzelne elemente und
natürlich am liebsten in social report
boxen
da kann man sich nämlich mit
zahnstochern fixieren und dann wurde ich
bei der autofahrt nichts
die kabine ist ein zerbrechliches teil
der torte deswegen transportiere ich die
auf meinem schoß und am besten fährt er
motorrad in einem anderen auto mit recht
besser
das ging schon mal netto hatte beim
transport kaputt durch deine frage
künste ist a1 wird alles ins auto
gepackt
[Musik]
so alle sist geladen
das nehme ich auf dem schoß und jetzt
geht's los
[Musik]
seit zimmer dach sind ausgeräumt und
dann kann ich die torte schon
zusammensetzen
jungs aus lahde
[Musik]
ich parke dem ist heiß auf die
kommunizierte auf das würde dann der
boden der acker mit ist
zusammengeschnitten und
zurechtgeschnitten und hier die
komplette fläche ausgelegt
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt ersatzteile von einem
spielzeug und da muss das v profi
natürlich immer nach vorne zeigen
jetzt kann ich die einmal durch den
mississippi durchfahren
[Musik]
habe ich das problem ich hätte den
puffern dazu rechnen soll er beim
erhöhen der platte habe ich hier ein
legostein drunter gebaut muss den reifen
hoch setzen weil es sonst hier nicht
dran passt
[Musik]
starfire receiver damit ist auch ein
intelligenter traktor wird also ein
denkfehler hatte ich drin und zwar
hinten die kabine die hätte ich hinten
schließen müssen
jetzt muss man halt improvisieren ich
habe verdammt dabei
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das letzte finish noch mal
ein bisschen schwarze lack darüber dass
alles schön glänzt man hat zwar fertig
und die wand haben jetzt aufgestellt
weil jetzt schon die ersten gäste
reinkommen und die sollen ja noch nicht
sehen was hier passiert ja das hab ich
die torte fertig und weist nun der bau
ist später reden möchte und machen wir
spontan wie immer jetzt kommt noch eine
signatur drauf der sally button
rotter
[Musik]
mehr kiste versteckt hatte etwas ich bin
so froh dass alles heil überstanden
haben man will ja mit aber mit john
deere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im anschluss an die geburtstagsfeier gab
es noch eine große autogrammstunde da
durfte mich meine zuschauer besuchen und
der kuchen wurde bis zum letzten krümel
auf gegessen was mich natürlich sehr
freut der mit seeblick und natürlich
auch der traktor weil der john deere
traktor 100 jahre alt wird bekommt ihr
jetzt auch die gelegenheit etwas zu
gewinnen anlässlich des geburtstags und
zwar haben wir drei ganz tolle gewinn
preise für euch der hauptgewinn ist eine
original john die armbanduhr und die
zwei weiteren gewinnen pakete beinhalten
spielsachen und john deere fanartikel
und falls ihr gewinnen wollt dann
hinterlasst einfach einen kommentar
unter diesem video schreibt einfach was
ich an diesem video am besten gefallen
hat und dann noch dazu zähle ich möchte
gewinnen
alle infos zum nachbacken gibt's auch
sallys blog.de mehr hat super viel spaß
gemacht und ich bedanke mich bei euch
bis einschalten bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
[Musik]